il appelle danyel waro ma les dionysiens
pure souche non championne maloya est
mal à créer mon entreprise en janvier
2014 nous joue c'est donc une entreprise
individuelle et qui propose 3 3 types
d'activités la première ce sont les jeux
géants longtemps donc je géants locaux
jeux géants d'ailleurs rosconi causé la
mort kours la rou
et puis des jeux plus contemporain avec
des grands carte pour adultes des caps
de karts à pédales des cartes pour les 4
8 ans et puis un espace voiture magique
pour les tout petits 2 4 ans la deuxième
activité basse et des contenus propose
des spectacles de contes mal et
raconteur d'histoires et mal est aussi
auteur compositeur interpelle donc
malina
répertoire
oh
ma dernière activité salariée péter dans
le domaine associatif mal à travailler
dans le domaine médico-social pendant 18
ans jusqu'à mi 2012 à peu près mal à
négocier une rupture conventionnelle est
mal à réorienter moins dans le domaine
de l'entrepreneuriat parce que me disais
moi c'était le moment ou jamais une
quand mal a pu négocier la rupture
conventionnelle mal à retrouver un an à
pôle emploi donc par ce biais mal à tous
des assedic et mal a appris l'existence
de la couveuse réussit mal a fait une
info collectivement la rencontre après
un chargé de projet mal à monter un
dossier que les passer devant une
commission est bonne a estimé que ça
tenait la route ce que me voulait mettre
en place
j'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir à voir
daniel sens et dans cette aventure parce
qu'effectivement c'est une aventure
et puis on a deux filles qui ont
effectivement aussi été les premiers à
tester le matériel à nous dire est que
ça va s que ça fonctionne qui prennent
beaucoup de plaisir venu à venir sur les
journées canton quand elles peuvent
et puis
c'est vrai que notre maison nous joue
est installé dans notre maison qu'on va
dire mon objectif premier c'était
d'arriver à être avoir une la moitié de
l'année en journées de prestation contes
musique ou jeux géants environ donc 150
journée la malle et au bout de deux ans
et demi atteint l'objectif de 100
journées mal et le seul berman en un an
deux ans mais
quand il ya une journée grosses comme
celles ci que les mises en place ou me
dois installer la majeure partie de mes
jeux mais fait appel à des personnes que
me rétribue sous forme de chèques tts
mal et parmi les 12 finalistes m'y
attendais pas moins honnêtement m'y
prends mal est content si mal et parmi
les six dernières personnes m'apprendre
aussi me sera très content mais ce n'est
pas pour la partie financière qui
rapporte même si mime à prendre avec
plaisir